now carlos carresco
will try to pitch them to another series
victory they stay one half game back of
minnesota in the al central victor reyes
reyes sends one to the right center
field gap and that will get down
allen makes a nice play on it reyes with
a head first slide and a leadoff double
for detroit chance for an rbi for miguel
cabrera
cabrera drives one to center allen's got
it reyes tagging
hurrying
and the tigers have the early lead
thanks to the sacrifice fly from miguel
cabrera today's starting pitcher for
detroit
is tarik skuba he's making his second
start and everybody knows that uh pretty
exciting to see this kid out cesar
hernandez batting right-handed
deep center back as jacoby jones at the
wall and it's gone a home run
cesar hernandez last one that nobody can
get to and we are tied at one second
inning luplow hitting sixth today in
left field
luklow drives one deep right center
field
and it's gonna short hop to wall
monifasio gets to it and jordan luke
will in the second base with a leadoff
double
the 2-2 domingo santana swung on him
missed and then the
follow-through kind of clipped grayson
greiner in the face mask third strikeout
of the day for carrick skubal
now he faces rookie beau taylor
can't hit that one either two away good
job there
two big outs now he's gonna face greg
allen the number nine hitter here's the
2-2
c
strikes out allen strikes out the side
after
the lead off double so you can see why
the tigers are high on
tarik skubal he's got some kind of arm
willy castro
he didn't hit anything that time swung
right through it third strikeout for
carrasco one down here in the third
tamer candelario steps to the plate
swung out of miss candelario goes
hacking throw down to complete the
strikeout jose ramirez there's a smash
to third and it absolutely ate up for
rabies
boy did it ever jose ramirez has himself
a one-ounce single pitching change for
daniel norris to come in it's his fifth
game
reyes is three for nine with a home run
and five strikeouts in the series ground
ball up the middle tips off the globe of
northfield to buy goodrum backhand flip
to castro at second for the force on
lindor looks like that deflection might
have helped daniel norris does the job
strands two inherited runners
at the plate first
nico goodram starts out the inning he
did get it
welcome back to the lineup nico goodrum
a solo blast to lead off the fourth and
detroit has reclaimed the lead
kobe jones takes ball one now he lines
one down the left field line he got
jammed but he muscled it down the left
field line over the field it is luplow
rounding first heading to second as
jacoby jones throw is cut off by
francisco lindor line drive double off
the bat of jacoby jones home run double
to start the fourth inning here's jorge
bonifacio he's got to go the middle big
part of the field is see
oh he sends it to deep left center
anybody going to catch that that ball is
out of here
a two-run blast
first homer
first hit
wearing the old english d for jorge
bonifacio and the tigers now with a 4-1
lead here in the fourth so kubert draws
a lead-off walk here in the fifth
chamber candelario here's the 1-1
swung on ground ball to short up with it
lindor to the back for one fernandez to
first double play
that's about as taylor made as they come
six four three on the twin killing jose
ramirez
drilled right center
and that's gonna go for two that was a
beautiful swing right there rosie now uh
two consecutive hits
the boy from the right side of the plate
he took that ball and shot it the other
way here comes francisco lindor
ground ball too short backhanded by
goodrich
and pulling off the bag the ball gets
loose ramirez on his way to third and
he'll get there safely
so the indians catch a break here on the
misfire and they've got two on with one
out romeo reyes the batter over two
fastball swing and a miss he got him up
in the strike zone with a live fastball
ron mill reyes strikes out good job by
daniel norris to overcome the error that
put runners at the corners racing
grinder
grinder turns on one oh he belted that
baby see ya home run number one and he
put a charge into it
and the tigers take a 5-1 lead here in
the sixth inning two outs two on here's
miguel cabrero here comes the 2-1
stroke to right
that'll drop
and reyes will be waved home
and he'll score easily
another rbi for miguel cabrera and now
tied for 21st in major league history
for miguel cabrera
seven hundred seven
rbis adds to the tigers lead they now
have a six one lead here the six nikko
goodram will lead it off
deep right center long run for greg
allen he dives and makes a phenomenal
catch for route number one that's a
four-star play by greg allen
all-out diving effort to take extra
bases away from nico goodroom leads it
up to willie castro
there's a base hit and an rbi single for
willy castro
and now it's 7-1 detroit greg allen two
strikeouts a fly out two on one out
ninth inning
greg allen lifts one in the air deep
right center field long run for
bonifacio and it's gone a home run
greg allen with a three-run homer here
in the bottom of the ninth and gets the
indians to within seven to four
a couple of hits for ramirez today here
comes the 1-1
candelario with a nice backhand and the
tigers win the series in cleveland
first time they have won a series from
the indians
since september of 2018.